defense or offense best basketball
player that came out of brooklyn why did
you blow in lebron's ear
[Music]
boys go faster come on
[Music]
oh
shoot
mommy's here
how much were your earrings
my earrings cost five thousand hey
what
both
each
thousand five thousand
it's a pair of earrings how did you ask
the first girl you like out of date
[Music]
actually
do you think i'm cute
let's go for a walk why did you blow
lebron's ear
[Music]
i just wanted to win
what was the first car that you ever
owned ss camaro
2011
favorite car and i still got it to this
day
can you tell me
what is your career points per game
average
[Music]
really you looking at my stats right now
the cars.com app it helps you pick out
your perfect car
for your lifestyle
really you not even only have to drive
yet so it's never too early to seek out
expert advice
[Music]
who's the best basketball player you've
ever seen
the best basketball player i've ever
seen larry bird and magic johnson
those guys
goats
who's the best basketball player that
came out of brooklyn
there's a lot of great ones you know i
gotta go with myself
[Music]
if you weren't a basketball player what
would you be doing right now
a teacher
my favorite subject that i would teach
is math yeah
[Music]
what's your favorite food to get in
indiana
my favorite food to get in indiana um
they make some good shrimp
[Music]
i don't like seafood
you don't like crabs
don't even say that terrible shrimp crab
oysters
that's nasty if you can eat oysters you
can eat boogers
what music do you like to listen to
before again i like to listen to arm
beach
i give it up to you guys
you